welcome to the car cast everyone so we
were talking yesterday about about the
the the reasons why young people have
left the church and I gave my theory my
theory is that young people are leaving
the church because the church has tried
to be trendy and cool it's tried to
appeal to the shallowest most
superficial aspects of young people
rather than appealing to their deeper
characteristics and that would be their
hunger for change and identity their you
know hunger for a cause to fight for a
mission
their radicalism their revolutionary
nature all that great stuff so it should
be a match made in heaven literally
between young people and Christianity
because Christianity is a radical
revolutionary cause right to fight for
but instead we've watered everything
down and in an attempt to make it more
palatable but really what's happened is
we've alienated everybody including
young people now it received a lot of
feedback to that discussion and I want
some of it positive some of it negative
as usual I wanted to I wanted to address
one objection one email because it
represents I think a lot of the
critiques that I read after we talked
about this so I got one I got an email
from a guy fellow Christian and he said
that he agreed with much of what I said
he agreed with the general argument for
the most part but he also thinks that
the real problem or one of the biggest
problems is that young people are really
repulsed
by the rules the so-called rules in
Christianity especially the rules
that govern governed their sex lives and
he said that if churches would
de-emphasize those things de-emphasize
the teachings on abstinence chastity
especially the idea that sex outside of
marriage is wrong if we DM ffice eyes
that that we might have a better shot of
bringing people in and this idea I've
heard echoed by many other people now I
have several objections to that
objection and I want to go through them
one at a time so first of all let's
start with this churches have
de-emphasized those things or outright
rejected them
and I find it fairly mind-boggling that
there are still so many people who think
that the church's main problem is that
it's too conservative and too Orthodox
and that it's too focused on rules and
that's you know the biggest problem is
all these Christians running around who
are fundamentalist and they're they're
so focused on religious discipline means
what where is that a problem where are
you meeting all these Christians who
that's their biggest issue I mean really
what are you talking about I have not
noticed that the vast vast majority of
Christians that you meet could care less
about the rules could care less about
the commandments
make no attempt to follow them
whatsoever in their lives and the vast
majority of churches that you go to
they'll never talk about these they're
not ever talk about sexual immorality
it's a chastity I mean really you think
look with all due respect I just
as I said I find it mind-boggling this
idea that
there's a problem with Christians being
too focused on chastity will you ever
hear anyone talking about chastity
anymore it's extremely rare and it's
extremely rare I'm just telling it's
extremely rare to find a church that
talks about these things okay
so the point is we have to emphasize
them we have liberalized and that's been
one of the great causes of the problem
which means it cannot be the solution
second
I don't like the term rules
to describe
teachings and commandments of God
because their their rules in the same
way that gravity is a rule
these things are inherent
the moral Commandments that you find in
the Bible
call them rules if you want to but they
are not random they're not arbitrary and
saying and calling them rules makes it
sound arbitrary and I think people use
that term on purpose they want it to
sound arbitrary they want to make it
sound like this is just something
Christians came up with or even
something that just God came up with
randomly just wanting to cramp our style
I guess
but that's not the case the moral laws
of Christianity are inherent they can be
found within human nature they are part
of the nature of things just like
gravity on a physical level this part of
the nature of things
so Christianity says that it's
destructive and disordered to lust after
women to sleep around the turn section
to a game to be promiscuous all that but
Christianity isn't just giving its
opinion it isn't just giving suggesting
one possible way to live that's equal to
all the other ways no it's it's telling
you something that's just true and every
person who's treated sex like a gay who
has lived by lust and self-indulgence
whether Christian or not has suffered
the misery and degradation that comes
with that lifestyle
just as every person who jumps from a
building has had to deal with the fact
that gravity is going to assert itself
and in the same way those moral laws
assert themselves
whether we choose to abide by them or
not
um
third thing
you say that people don't want rules
they don't want Commandments they don't
want to be told what to do
I disagree I think now on the surface
that might be true again surface level
it's true that people don't want to be
told what to do on a deeper level I
think people are starving to be told
what to do they're starving for
direction for instruction they're
starving for lines to be drawn
they are
I think when you go to someone and you
say do what you are any whatever you
want do anything that you want it's all
equal there's no bad there's no good
everything's equally as bad he could we
is good anything you want to do Jess go
do it now they might be happy at first
they might say Oh awesome great
but in the end they're going to be lost
and confused and paralyzed
in fact tell somebody that come back the
next day you know what they're gonna be
doing they'll probably still just be
standing right there they haven't gone
anywhere
when you've told them every direction as
equal is equal and nothing is better
than any else it's like I don't
okay what's the point of going anywhere
then
it's kind of like it's kind of a crude
analogy here but it's sort of like um if
you go to one of these chain restaurants
where it seems like the menus of these
restaurants just grow by the minute
and so now you open up a menu and there
are six thousand things on it every
variety is there's a to Mexican food
Italian food American food you know
everything
and what happens that you have no idea
it's too many options you don't even
know it's you have no idea what to and
then what do you do you end up asking
the waiter but what do you think I
should get you need some direction you
need someone to help you like just this
is too much
it's too many options give me some
clarity here
give me some direction get me some
advice or something
don't just give me 6,000 options and say
eat whatever you want right so it kind
of works that way morally in our lives
there are two types of freedom
there are there's the freedom of a life
devoid of all meaning of all purpose of
the devoid of Direction devoid of
morality there's that freedom where
there's no rules and then there's the
freedom that you find in truth and in
God
there's the freedom that you find when
you willingly surrendered to
um
the moral Commandments
that God has given us
when you surrender to God
so there's this free there's the freedom
in pride where you say I'm gonna do
whatever I want and then there's the
freedom in surrender to God
saying show me the way and I will walk
the freedom that we find when God has
not only told us but he's shown us Jesus
Christ walked the path and he said
follow me
he didn't say just go do whatever you
want everything's equal nothing's worked
bad nothing's good there's no sin he
said follow me and so when you follow
him you find true freedom
even if in this life you're also going
to find suffering and sacrifice and all
that
so that's the only true freedom that's
where you can really be happy
but in order to enjoy that freedom you
have to follow the quote rules
just as you have to follow the rule of
gravity after you have to obey its
dictates respect it understand it if you
want to enjoy skydiving
okay skydiving with a parachute is
controlled it's restricted
there are rules if you want to do it
you've never done before you gotta go
take a class and they get they give you
all the different instructions you fill
out forms you do everything right there
are a lot of rules I've never been
skydiving my understanding though is
there are a lot of rules with skydiving
and
so there's no you could do it that way
or you could do it the freeway and you
could really be free and you could
skydive without a parachute
one is fun and exciting the other is
suicide
so which way is actually free
the one where you splatter on the
pavement and die at the end
or the one where you learn the rules and
you respect them and you follow them
and
you know
you take the more controlled and
restricted approach another example I
think we could look at marriage in
modern times you know we've done away
with all the roles all the rules all the
idea all ideas of duty and
responsibility we've done away with the
man's Authority and headship in the home
and now we say everything's 50/50 there
are no roles there are no rules there
are no duties there are no
responsibilities that anyone in
particular is supposed to be be doing
everyone just does everything nobody
leads nobody follows nobody's in charge
nobody nothing right there's no head of
the home
now and and so this is this is supposed
to be a free marriage right they free
and equal marriage where everyone just
can do whatever they want
now I ask you has this led to happy and
fulfilled marriages across the country I
can't even say it without laughing even
though it's not funny
but it is it's just the absurdity of
this idea that it's actually worked out
right
do you think it's worked out
because I look across the country and I
see divorce I see you know unhappy and
miserable people in their marriages I
see I see an entire generation of people
my generation who have almost given up
on marriage completely they take such a
dim view of it
so has this equal 50/50 free and open
approach to marriage has it worked
No
instead again it's caused this paralysis
people in relationships don't know what
they're supposed to do they don't know
who's supposed to do what
now with gender roles
bad old ancient gender roles people knew
basically what they're supposed to do in
a marriage
within those you know within those
parameters there's a lot of freedom and
still there's a lot of diversity in
marriages and marriages can you know are
all different because there are
different people involved in them but
when you have this basic idea of gender
roles well now at least you you can get
going you can go in one direction
because you know where you're supposed
to go and you have a general idea of
what you're supposed to be doing but we
don't have that anymore so people don't
know what they're supposed to do how
they're supposed to relate and then what
what happens is competition arises and
they end up competing and working
against each other because they've
rejected the roles the rules that help
them make their marriages work and help
them work with each other so that they
can enjoy a happy and complimentary and
free marriage fourth thing
and this point is related to all the
rest that I've mentioned but you say
that young people aren't interested in
chastity and abstinence and sexual
morality
once again that is only on the surgeons
on the surface yet they're not
interested
let's look at a deeper level deeper
level
we could see that the alternative has
not been a great success
modern sexuality like modern marriage on
surprisingly two are linked modern
sexuality is a disaster zone it's it's a
catastrophe disease abortion unwed
pregnancy porn addiction the sexual
revolution has been a catastrophic
failure
people are not happy
find me someone my age 31 32 who's been
sleeping around and dating frivolously
for the last 10 or 15 years or longer
and yet is happy
and satisfied and content
not lonely at all find me someone like
that you can't
they're all miserable
all the people that have tried it this
way they followed the ideas of the
sexual revolution they've wanted to be
free sexual freedom
I mean look at you know we had a baby
boomers came along my parents generation
and they said I want sexual freedom and
what do we end up with disease abortion
death divorce I mean all these that's
what freedom has gotten us
is destruction and despair
people are unfulfilled in the romantic
lives and worse than that they feel
violated
what do you think all this affirmative
consent stuff is about you have women
who they have sex consensually and the
next day they claim that they were
assaulted because they they was config
they volunteered to do it but they
volunteered and they had reservations
and they didn't stay with unspoken
reservation and there's there was
something in the back of their mind
telling them know that this isn't right
don't do this but they did it anyway
now what is that stem from
they feel violated because they were
violated though they offer themselves up
to be violated
they feel degraded because they were
degraded
though they were willing participants in
their own degradation they wake up
feeling used because they were used
though they allowed themselves to be
used which makes them feel even worse
because now there's guilt
you
and nobody can really be happy with that
you see what we've done is
you find this over and over and over
where somebody comes in
and they get rid of the rules they get
rid of the moral any sense of morality
they get rid of all that
and then what and then catastrophe and
disaster soon follows and so then they
try to make new rules the whole idea was
to get rid of rules and now they're
making new ones and the new ones are
even more restricting and weird and
bizarre and confusing than the old ones
and so what's happened is we've got rid
of all that all of them the moral laws
and you know all any sense of sexual
morality we've tossed out the window the
only thing that we've left is consent
that was the one last thing now consent
was already embedded into Christian
sexual morality consent was part of it
Christianity has always been against
rape very clearly so that was already
part of it but there was more to it
because Christianity recognizes that
yeah you have to consent to a sexual act
but that's just that's just the
beginning that's that in itself is not
enough you could consent to a sexual act
and yet still be harmed by it physically
and spiritually and so there's got to be
more than just consent but what our
culture has said is no consent Saul that
mattered but what are they found they
found that Christianity was right
there's got to be more that's consent is
not enough because people are consenting
to sex and yet they still feel awful and
guilty and empty and ashamed the next
day and so what our culture has tried to
do is they try to take consent and use
it as the raw material to build this
whole new sexual ethic and they've
turned consent into this like calculus
this is impossible to understand
calculus whereas it should be pretty
simple it's consent if you did you did
you participate in the act willingly if
you did then you consented if you were
forced into it you weren't you didn't
you didn't consent really simple but now
we've tried to take consent and find a
way to use it so as to in some way still
protect the dignity of of women so that
even if so there could be a situation
where they volunteer to do it yet they
didn't consent because they're gonna
feel violated afterwards and so it just
becomes very confusing
it's not so confusing if you go back to
the Christian sexual morality which says
that sex is a sacred thing it's a
beautiful wonderful precious thing
and it has to be protected
it's also very powerful
it's powerful because sex can create a
whole other person
which is pretty incredible
also powerful on a spiritual emotional
level
where you no matter what you try to say
you know you when you when you offer
yourself up to somebody like this and
you are
with someone in this most intimate way
imaginable
your whole being gets wrapped up into it
as well
and so their emotions get involved in
all this and there's this kind of this
bond that naturally and automatically
forms
Christianity recognizes that and so says
okay this thing it's not because we hate
sex no it's because we understand we
understand how powerful and wonderful
this thing is and so we have to respect
it
serve it for the the protected
parameters of a committed and loving and
devoted marriage
Christianity says that any other
arrangement leads to despair misery and
destruction and the world has proved
this correct the last 60 years of
American history have been one long case
study proving Christian sexual ethics
correct
you don't have to take my word for it
just look at the culture look at what's
happened
so no it's not it's not Christian
Christianity doesn't hate sex our
culture hates sex
it has turned it into this meaningless
empty thing like just a recreational
activity and nothing more like a like a
greeting between people like it's just
shaking hands with a person it's having
sex that's what our culture has done
they hate and are afraid of what sex sex
actually is whereas Christianity
embraces it in its totality and says
this is a good thing that comes from God
it's so good in fact that you you can't
just give it away
you can't just let it be used
it's got to be protected like anything
else that's precious and valuable and
personal and intimate you protect it you
don't just give it to anybody
this is why Christians believe or should
believe even saving it for marriage now
and teachings especially in the area of
sex are difficult to follow
but as Chesterton's and maybe will see
us Louis Oh
Chesterton or Louis what are those guys
said that Christianity has not been
tried and found wanting
it's been found difficult and left
untried so we have here an essential
choice between the difficult but better
thing or the easy but worst thing
and I like I like that matchup personal
that's a compelling argument I like that
argument
that matchup between difficult better
easy worse
that's good I like our chances of
winning that argument
but if we're going to win that argument
we have to make it first
and so you say oh no the church needs to
back away from sexual morality all
morality don't talk about it
I say we should do the exact opposite
just talk to me should we talk about it
a lot more
because people need to hear this and
they want to also even if they don't
know
because they're not happy with the other
way
no matter what they claim they're not
happy with
they want to find happiness and
fulfillment here it is we got to tell
them about we can't be afraid to tell
them we can't be in [ __ ] ashamed or
embarrassed we are not the ones who
should be ashamed or embarrassed of this
belief system because it's right and
it's true
alright thanks for watching everybody
have a great day and Godspeed